A number of women have come forward.
They've made allegations against your husband.
Some of them go back more than 30 years.
He's said they're lying.
Do you believe him?
I believe my husband.
This was all organized from the opposition.
And with the details, did they ever check the background of these women?
They don't have any facts.
And even the story that came out in People magazine,...
...the writer that, she said that my husband took her to the room...
...and start kissing her.
She wrote in the same story about me that she saw me on 5th Avenue and I said to her,...
"Natasha, how come we don't see you anymore?"
I was never friend with her.
I would not recognize her.
That never happened?
Never happened.